yeah welcome to this video playing a 15
minute game and this real tough one
playing bones this is grandma's down
Frank ho let's go from from Germany it's
a long time bundesliga player strong GM
above 2500 and good occasion to test
this this line I played c3 quickly
probably knowing knowing a bit a bit
about this probably more than me but a
while ago I did this as already
mentioned a couple of times this video
series for the ICC on this opening and
but i forgot feel quite quite a bit
about my recommendations going to be
three gap intending am intending on
rather positional kind of game the text
be seven so i cannot easily move the
bishop then it's also maybe introduces
the idea of playing a Bishop to c4 now
Bishop c4 i still have Queenie for check
or sometimes they'll grab so it's not a
big threat still on I need to consider I
don't think I want to take the sound
doesn't look too great Knight to d7 to
be six or some possibility but all 97
he's got this
check has mentioned and this Bishop c4 I
mean but I can take g2 and how does he
defend at the end probably he doesn't
became so let's do this the ship see for
Quincy to Bishop f7 check king d 8 and
he's got no way to defend the rukon h1
so Bishop c4 is not possible if he
exchanges on d5 it's immediately okay
improving my 4th structure even further
so that I have an excellent central
control this double porn by the way here
is not really the problem for blanket
this is not a bad structure the problem
is more like the H poem sometimes the
h-bond can can be weak and deep in the
end game the edge pawn can be a problem
but in the middle game this is not
really an issue those double pants
control on many important squares in the
center now I am expect on a move like
Knight f3 you've just developing after
which i probably will play night to be 6
yeah I to be sick son I must react to
this idea Nazi form yeah I had this
before I was in trouble I remember now
not against him but in some in some
other blitz game tweenie formula we can
interpose and he's always got the c5
idea
yeah I guess then I intend to to play
this more often I need to examine this
queen bee three move it looks some quite
quite problematic
I problematic is very the wrong word I
don't think it should be so dangerous
but you need to know what you're doing
and I'm obviously not know knowing what
i'm doing this already looks a bit bit
tricky okay let's stop prop g8 tickling
him on now on the G pawn now I cannot
really develop this Bishop always c5 and
takes on b7 they can really take p7 yeah
now White has some discoveries but I
don't think that's a really good one at
least I hope you've liked I am ok
yeah he wants to earn probably catch the
Rookie of a ticket but maybe I can can
play this and get rid of the Queen's
with Queen a fall it doesn't look
particularly great but maybe still the
some gives me some mum some relief from
them from the pressure the idea is
Bishop d2 Queen a form or otherwise
improving the Queen position 92s a
strange reply probably just perfectly
too
yeah if he goes King everyone hmm yeah
still Queen a4 or not yeah this I I had
dismissed earlier I thought I mean I
didn't really calculate it too deeply
but I thought you five looks like a good
reply and also even if I just take it
and then okay let's play if I first this
is Sir the first thing I need to do
without much much debate this helps to
develop the f8 bishop and just wins wins
an important temple
what idea of this is if him for example
place um okay place it simply but he
didn't then there would have been ideas
with with opinion okay interesting he
takes on you five with the porn later
next move I've got Bishop to c5 this is
very important I think
hmm
hmm yeah quite interesting this position
especially and this is optionally he
takes on e5 and then Bishop c5 this
looks quite good interesting at least
okay let's not not spend too much time
now now this is hanging into a probably
needs to take then Bishop c5 yeah not
much choice he needs to take this now
this this move winning a temple
yeah I've got pretty decent development
now and where's he going to
it's it's possible that you can simply
take everything here and get away with
it but maybe I really have some some
sort of compensation so it's not
completely impossible and I'm not sure
what you should play yet that yeah this
is probably but what now even the
somewhat signals a fire versus something
to look at the normal would be a long
class all looks very active and he
cannot castle then short yeah let's not
waste too much time this is the most
active looking move if it's not the best
one not much I can do about it galop de
force the idea and I'm utilizing this
pin so after cancelling short I can just
take the two
and now i'm probably intending group
deform instead of castling long i could
also take me five play f5 those kind of
ideas but this looks okay not not sure
what white should do now taking f6 this
is risky if everything else fails it's
risky I was intending to say of because
of group GT v8 that maybe the school
five after that mm no but not just
happen ok so I'm night lucchese to EA to
move if he takes on f6 taking on f6 this
really as simple greed you move yeah
it's not easy to play in a practical
game at least in computer-aided analysis
um you quite often get positions where
you are defending and simply manage
because the computer finds all those
precise only moves that keep it together
we actually took it mrs. Sam this is a
surprise
rook d for Andrew creates this is this a
good simple solution
Arak create to the other the other idea
wait wait wait wait was thinking of me
taking on c4 but that's not working and
why exactly not talking about Bishop
Bishop Bishop Bishop Bishop c4 maybe
Queenie five
come on let's I don't want us to get
into a completely outlandish time issues
at the end they won't want to be at
least honest on his time level and not
burn too much time then they're probably
many a continuation that are interesting
at least the IE grabbed another pawn but
no I'm threatening luke t to enter the
bishop on f4
I probably am will take on the two not
so sure what he is playing now okay is
already m13 pawns so it's
it's not entirely clear but it's also
not clear what you should move now so
how does he actually secure skin I mean
I'm also attacking a form so if you
castles i just take f4 and if you place
the move like Bishop e3 rock t 2 i'm
already gaining instant threats so to be
honest i don't know what is yeah this
one what you should play was what i
wanted the same mmm yeah f4 hangs but
the question is if i take it yeah night
be three
yeah of course I would like to do is
also and want to check if I can can get
some mathematical might be three it's
rather rather annoying take on the aid
and stuff yeah still what what else am I
supposed to do maybe maybe there was
something better I don't know I hope on
c7 I've got a good good flight square
maybe can take on the 8th route d1 check
windy three this could be a quite quite
unlucky this could be a problem
something like this now yeah well he's
also struggling just inventing stuff as
it comes along he never intended to give
up this this piece on her form and and
and to get into this position but it
happened can also give her GA check
night GA check and King c 7q into g3 and
it's a very very ugly situation but
Bishop the successive would reply to
that okay at least something yep
look do you one I have 937 this is this
looks like a good reply of 97
but just two just in just a minute just
a minute check a look-see for quickly
hugs you form it's not a direct one this
is some covering d8 covering c5 and so
on it looks like a like an ammonia
smooth on Queen g3 I have 56 so I
threaten immediately rook takes you form
yeah this is looking looking nicely
maybe I'm American I can score an upset
here it's really a good player
yeah this is X I suspect the English is
a difficult language sometimes I suspect
that I'm quite good here but it's not
not yet over of course the problem for
widest my pieces are now quite well
coordinated and I'm attacking all kinds
of material f6c for f2 especially F to
assume is just a problem because it did
it all falls apart Queen f2 is a huge it
a huge threat and it's everything's
connected gasps should win this really
it's just a flat-out winning position
yeah Queen f2 I thought simple and
strong Queen d3 a proxy for a proxy form
and King be one especially f5 and resins
it's not be be too quick here yeah but
it is working no need to wait here
unnecessarily why yes nice when the this
opening claims another scalp somewhere
here I don't know probably something
went wrong white but it's not easy very
complicated stuff here I just expected
Bishop b2 with with a normal position
are done okay he played this yeah
computer wants to take g2 but it's not
the you move I play five okay here and
now yeah there should be six and castles
this is also the Commonwealth with a big
edge for black this is cool but probably
not because of the continuation that I
played he once so whether the computer
wants to castle now our bishops you far
ok and now long castles is what I played
computer wants to go f5 and take g2 yeah
okay but it's this bad no it isn't i
mean the computer is really good enough
technically to to check in a couple of
seconds if there's a technical issue but
it's exactly how the computer wants to
play is scary yeah but it's not so
difficult i mean this is hanging and
hooked it to is the threat
just activating through the utmost
adhere there's also this rookie for idea
takes 24 eggs yeah 97 yeah yeah yeah NTM
after King b1 this Bishop f5 and and
resigns yeah I really played lots of
computer moves this is Sir quite quite
surprising yeah looked like a pretty
decent game I mean probably here he
needs to play in some simple fashion
here and not grab material but I I
didn't think it is so bad but it seems
to be tricky f5 he has also quite good
the computer recommendation yeah
interesting game thanks for watching